à l'armée russe confirme avoir détruit
ce matin l'un de ces vieux satellites en
orbite cela provoquait un passage de
débris spatiaux à proximité de la
station spatiale internationale
conduisant les sept personnes
actuellement à bord dont deux
cosmonautes russes à se réfugier dans
leur vaisseau en vue d'une éventuelle
évacuation d'urgence un acte
irresponsable selon washington et l'otan
condamnation également de paris il n'y a
eu aucun risque pour les ss répond
moscou qui dénonce des accusations
hypocrite la correspondance de nice
d'esprit
washington a accusé ce lundi moscou
d'avoir procédé à un tir de missiles
antisatellites ayant mis en danger
l'équipage de la station internationale
un tir condamné aussi bien par paris que
par l'otan
pas plus tard qu'aujourd'hui la
fédération de russie a imprudemment
procéder à un essai destructeur d'un
missiles antisatellites à ascension
directe contre l'un de ses propres
satellites
ce test a généré à ce jour plus de 1500
débris orbitaux traçable et des
centaines de milliers de débris orbitaux
plus petit qui menace désormais les
intérêts de toutes les nations en outre
ce test augmentera considérablement le
risque pour les astronautes et des
cosmonautes de la station spatiale
internationale en ainsi que pour les
autres activités de vol spatial humain
le comportement dangereux et responsable
de la russie met en péril la viabilité à
long terme de l'espace extra
atmosphérique et démontre clairement que
les prétentions de la réussi à s'opposer
à la militarisation de l'espace sont
fallacieuses et hypocrite les etats-unis
travailleront avec leurs alliés et
partenaires pour répondre à l'acte
irresponsable de la russie pour le
ministère russe de la défense washington
fait preuve d'hypocrisie
lorsqu'il accuse moscou de créer des
risques pour les astronautes de l'iss ss
et appelle à mettre en place des normes
universelles de l'exploration spatiale
pour la communauté internationale en
2020 les états unis ont créé le space
com end et ont adopté officiellement une
nouvelle stratégie spatiale dont l'un
des principaux objectifs est de créer un
avantage militaire globale dans l'espace
à son tour le pentagone avant même ces
mesures officielles et encore plus après
développe activement et s en orbite sans
aucune notification ses dernières armes
d'attac et de combats de divers types y
compris les dernières versions de la
navette sial sans pilote x 37 les
actions de la partie américaine sont
considérés comme une menace et sont
incompatibles avec les objectifs
déclarés d'utilisation pacifique de
l'espace le ministère russe de la
défense reconnaît par ailleurs avoir
détruit ce lundi un satellite russe
toutefois d'après moscou washington
c'est que les débris formé lors de ce
test ne représente aucune menace pour
les ss la russie affirme que les
activités qu'elle mène dans l'espace
sont planifiés il vise à renforcer sa
capacité de défense en excluant toute
menace pour sa sécurité